to be honest they were kind of put in a
position
who's that joe and royce okay they
didn't know
that this album was coming out
so
i kind of afforded them
you know
a little elbow room
to be emotional
and
you know
try to address it in the best way that
they could being caught off guard like
that
you know what i'm saying um
now
within that i'm trying to say that you
know
maybe that's the reason that the story
doesn't add up
you see i'm saying because it's like yo
what are we gonna say
you feel me but
point blank no fat no no opinions no no
lies no
just straight facts
i brought the deal to the table okay
i told the guys i need to get on a phone
call with all of them
i couldn't get in contact with joe
because joe said he never actually saw a
deal right joe never called me so
so
i got on twitter
and i said hey guys because i talked to
my
supporters you're very active on twitter
on twitter very much a hundred percent
so i say hey guys
i didn't tell them about the deal i just
like yo y'all want to see the gang back
together i'm giving everybody 48 hours
to call me
okay
48 hours went by royce hit me
yo what's going on that's when i say yo
this is what's going on i got this deal
it's it's a great opportunity for us
there's ownership involved you know
we're going to be able to do our thing
roll it out how we want to roll it out
everything is laid out
you know we good
all right
we just need to all get on the phone so
he calls joe
all right so joe
i don't want to do it
okay
joe calls joelle man what's crook doing
on twitter
he got everybody in my telling me to
call him yeah right right right
well he got this deal joe and yada yada
well i don't want to do the deal and i
don't want to be the one to [ __ ] on
crook right now about this deal so i'm
gonna call i'm gonna think about it but
i'm gonna call crook in a couple hours
and then this was relayed to you from
royce from
from joelle
told me that to expect a call from joe
in an hour okay
and he was going to tell me why he
didn't want to do the deal
assuming you never got the call never
got the call
royce called me a couple of times i
remember like it was yesterday i was
getting a cover test because i was going
to hawaii mm-hmm i was at the airport
and
he said yo so joe said
he don't think that's a good deal
you know the thing the the the the deal
memo points that i kind of conveyed to
race race towed joe so essentially the
advance amount uh yeah all that [ __ ]
advance about it
percentages whatever
so i said well
i tell you what royce
tell joe to call me
we all get on the phone and whatever joe
wants
we'll give it to him
because i got juice like that
with the people that i'm working with
people so we have full contacts who are
the people that offer the deal
well
one of my business partners has
distribution through every major that
there is okay and he's a business
partner of mine outside of music too
and i've been doing business with him
he's like a brother to me so
this guy
was in a position where he wanted to
bankroll the situation he could bankroll
it he could if you just wanted to
bankroll it yourself
you know you could just use the whatever
so he had but he was gonna bankroll it
so based on what what those deal points
were joe was joe said he didn't want to
do it okay
and i told royce to give me a call i can
get joe whatever he wants to get put
into the paperwork but i'm not gonna go
back and forth and you know with the
attorneys and let's see this and let's
see that's just tell me what you want
we've all been in the game past 20
something years we know what contracts
look like tell me exactly what you want
we'll put in the contract and then we'll
start from there we'll start from what
you want john wherever you want you know
i mean and i was doing that honestly as
a courtesy to royce because i got love
for royce you know i mean i already was
at a point where this was my last time
ever trying to do business with joe
button again so i got love for roy so i
said you know what as a courtesy
we'll do that you know what i mean to
try to see
if we can get the fans this this this
last album so
you know he's like alright man y'all got
to talk about it i'm i'm like yeah
because he's he he's being the middle
man
joe was using royce as a middleman to
con to communicate with me i didn't like
that because joe because royce is a
general
and i start feeling like why is he
trying to use this man as a foot soldier
you know what i'm saying this dude is a
general all men are created equal we all
should be on the phone together it's no
reason you shouldn't be calling me right
now so he didn't call he never called
weeks went by months went by and it was
like everybody just went back to their
corners and i never even heard back
about the deal did you know none of that
stuff it was just over man so
you know
um and once roy said it he didn't want
to do it as a three-man crew which he's
totally entitled to right once he said
that it was like well
this [ __ ] is over
you know what i'm saying is
i don't think
i don't think that
what i could have communicated better to
royce because
as a friend
i could have communicated it better to
him that
i'm only talking to joe for you
i i would prefer to move slaughterhouse
forward without joe because joe is
retired and there's been a lot of snags
dealing with joe in the business side of
things so i would rather move
slaughterhouse forward without joe but
as a courtesy to my friend
and i know you [ __ ] with joe and i know
you have a different relationship with
joe yeah that's fine bring joe to the
table but i don't think that
as a friend i don't think that i
communicated that
enough he knows where i'm at
but i feel like he felt like he could
massage the situation crook got love for
me joe got love for me i could probably
be the glue to to keep all that [ __ ]
together you know what i mean but he
didn't know that i was at my
last final breaking point with joe or
joe as far as the slaughterhouse
situation goes